- [Nathan] My mission was
to make Oak Glen Petting Zoo
a destination, what they
needed was a star animal.
The plan to create a hero
pig by staging a viral video
in which he rescues a
baby goat from drowning.
- Oh, okay.
- So I think if you had a
video like that people would
come from places as foreign as Japan
and even more foreign like China.
Just to see your hero pig.
- That would be great.
- The first step was picking our animals.
Vince would be our hero pig
and Gangsta the goat would be our victim.
The zoo had a large trout pond
so this would be the setting
for our rescue.
But when I brought Vince near the water
I realized he was an incredible coward.
(pig squealing)
Okay, okay.
So we hired some animal
handlers to bring in
a professional movie pig that
looked identical to Vince.
The question now was how do we get a pig
to rescue a goat on camera?
Answer, you can't.
So I decided to have two scuba
divers secretly submerged
beneath the animals guiding
the pig towards the goat
to make it look like a real rescue.
During the first couple
attempts the pig kept slipping
out of the diver's hands.
So we decided to build an
underwater track out of PBC
to guide the pig like a bowling ball
going down a bumper lane.
This worked a lot better and
I was hopeful it would fool
the internet audience into
believing this video was real.
But as the amount of people
involved began to grow
including animal trainers,
stuntmen and Humane Society reps,
I started to get worried after
all word couldn't get out
that this was fake or it
would be a disastrous scandal
for Oak Glen.
So I asked everyone on set to
sign non-disclosure agreements
stating that they swore not to tell anyone
the rescue was fake or
else they would face
the death penalty even
though my lawyer said
the death penalty clause
was not enforceable,
I still wanted to keep it in there
so people knew how serious I was.
After several failed attempts
we finally got the rescue on tape
(goat crying)
(dramatic music)